LOGAN ROY: Just wanted to say
there are a lot of whispers
going around,
but I'm not going to make
an announcement tonight.
Tomorrow, we'll figure it out.
So...
Someone's getting shitcanned.
Let's get the party started.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
In the writer's room, we always
called it a balloon debate,
which I don't know if you have
that phrase in the U.S. of like,
you're in a hot air balloon
and it's sinking,
who do you throw out
to let everyone else live?
There's an element of that
in the middle of the episode.
I think the obvious choice
is... Tom.
KARL MULLER: Tom works.
Anyone care to speak
to my qualities?
-No. Tom looks logical.
-What?!
If it should be me,
why shouldn't it be you?
I'm not attacking you,
I'm defending you.
Well, it doesn't feel like that,
doesn't feel like it.
Tom comes under the spotlight
as a really--
quite a compelling candidate
to get the chop.
He feels unsupported by Shiv,
which I guess snowballs
into him revealing
a bunch of other feelings
about the relationship.
I'm not... a hippie.
I don't want to do threesomes.
If I think about it,
I think a lot of the time,
I'm really pretty unhappy.
I think the relationship
is complex,
and they both get different
things from each other.
In regard to the elements
of the show,
it's about that delicate moment
of which you say,
"That's too much.
I can't do this anymore."
-KENDALL ROY: Hey, Dad.
-LOGAN: Hey, son.
The hearings, you did so well.
And now...
you're the face.
You're across the cleanup,
the optics make sense.
And, what's more, I trust you.
I guess Logan feels that--
that Kendall's a good candidate.
You know, I think he has
a certain amount
of residual resentment
against him
because of what happened
in the previous season.
Kendall is somebody he can
really trust.
In a situation like that,
you need someone
who's not gonna flip,
or do exactly what Kendall does.
The truth is, that my father
is a malignant presence...
(GASPS, MURMURING)
...a bully, and a liar,
and he was fully
personally aware
of these events for many years
and made efforts to hide
and cover up.
We knew pretty early on,
the shape of the season
for Kendall,
from where he begins,
which is in this entirely
submissive, really beaten dog,
who ends up denouncing
his father.
It felt like a true shape to us,
you know,
as long as we could honor
all the different stages
of that journey.
This is the day his reign ends.
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
They're in trouble.
They've got a shareholder
meeting in a couple of weeks,
which is on a knife edge,
and is not going to have been
helped
by the revelation by Kendall
that Logan was completely across
all the corporate misdeeds
of the company.
The family relationships
are gonna be something
of a shit show.
So, it's either well-poised
or a terrible mess,
depending on how you look at it.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪